good sweet hi hi Thanks for meeting us
here in yerba buena gardens thank you
for having me and tell me who you are
Internet lady internet lady I am Sara
Haider also known as panda Mona on the
internet which was my old Warcraft name
my main character I am an Android
engineer I work at a company called
secret right here in the Bay Area two
blocks away so you've been playing wife
since vanilla right
since vanilla since closed beta actually
so early November 2004 I stood in line
with my college friends on November 23rd
2004 and we bought it at 8:00 in the
morning went home probably skipped
school for about two weeks and play it
on and off for the past ten years but
pretty hardcore for the first few we
were rating and a guild I had friends
that I played with in real life then we
were part of a larger guild when I
started working it probably petered off
but every once in a while I go back and
see what's going on you work the Twitter
as well for a bunch of years I did yeah
you said something interesting to me
over Twitter actually funnily enough how
your experience communicating with
people have that kind of benefited you
with your work at Twitter yeah so I mean
I was in college and I wasn't thinking
about people management or anything like
that but you know you especially in the
early days when raids were 40 men you've
got 40 guys that have to be focused for
eight hours and everyone has needs some
some people have babies crying some
people have different goals for what
they want to get out of the raid most of
the time you go on these eight-hour
raids and you don't get any loot out of
it and you know that going in and how do
you keep all those people focused for a
long period of time how do you keep them
on track making sure they're not pulling
extra ads in wiping out the raid getting
everyone else frustrated and you know by
the time you get to the eighth hour you
may not even kill boss
and at the time there were you know
seven-day cooldown so you'd have to lay
the entire seven days to do all over
again and that was a challenge in people
management and leadership what I learned
was that leadership is more than just
giving orders and saying you go there
you heal this you do that it was about
listening listening to people
understanding everyone's needs and
making sure you could try to stay on
task as efficiently as possible and it's
the same thing when you're managing a
team at a company and when you're when
you're dealing with people because
everyone has real life problems
everyone's got their own stuff and how
do you keep people on task so that you
can actually build something that's when
I started to worry about that is it
easier to manage 40 person raves than it
is to manage a team of people at Twitter
sometimes sometimes I mean everyone is
that you know everyone's playing for fun
and the challenges are very similar it's
funny we're sort of sitting here in
yerba buena and there's people wandering
past on their lunch breaks just kind of
hanging out with friends or having
meetings do you think there's like this
clandestine world of people who have all
played Wow and nobody really knows it
but you're just passing well yeah it was
passing them all the time
for sure I mean for a game that's ten
years old it affected so many people
there's bound to be people that you
didn't expect that played it that you
know are hiding out there
especially in Silicon Valley
you
you